We had the Roman Empire,
the Spanish and the British empire.
Now we live in the age of the American
mm.
No,
the country has had such a military
presence in so many places,
even in remote places like Guam in the
middle of the Pacific,
America has a military base and that's
actually pretty useful
that you can buy a mobile phone made in
South Korea with just one click.
That's the outcome of global capitalism,
but also global capitalism would not be
possible if trade wasn't safe.
Those American bases there,
there to protect those ships that move
goods from one place to another,
and this is really the reason why the US
invest so much in having a strong army,
which has kind of been unchallenged
until now.
So now you might be wondering or you
might not be who is challenging this
empire because of course it's shine up
and swell.
How is trying to doing this?
Well,
that's what we're going to see in this
video.
This is the million dollar question.
Why does America have such a big army?
You might argue that it doesn't really
need one.
In fact that just by looking at a map,
you can see that America has a big
advantage.
It's secured by two fairly sizable
oceans,
making it almost impossible to attack or
invade.
Nonetheless,
America has the biggest army on the
planet.
It has more than a million active
military personnel and almost 800
military bases located in 70 different
countries.
Territories all over the globe,
risen,
France and Russia by contrast have about
34 and bases combined.
Just have a look at this map.
America is all over the place and there
is no country that can challenge them.
Well,
hold on a second because maybe there is.
Yes,
you have us.
Today we're talking all about Schneider.
Errol,
visitable.
I think we've talked to thousands of
times about China's economic progress.
It's the world's factory and many
Chinese companies are starting to become
big competition for the technological
bandits,
but now we're talking about then
military more specifically than military
presence in the south China Sea,
and believe me,
this is no
joke.
China,
south China Sea play the end of peaceful
rise.
The definition string of pearls was
first used in 2005 in an international
report given by the Department of
Defense of the United States.
In this report,
it was predicted that China will try to
expand its naval presence throughout the
Indian Ocean region.
In this context,
the polls are a metaphor for each of the
military bases that China wants to
build,
making a string that goes all the way
down to Africa and the Middle East where
China imports most of its natural
resources and as you can imagine,
these military extensions,
they scanned the wells,
especially America,
and they got even more scary when the
former trainees,
President Hu Jintao,
sent this in 2009
the road.
The peaceful development is a strategic
choice made by the Chinese government
and people in the line of the nations
peace loving traditional culture.
The trend of our times and the
fundamental interests of China who
gentle.
Yeah,
so for some reason,
this quote that was intended to chill
out via Americans basically had the
opposite effect because it pretty much
sounded like China was saying the
opposite of what is actually the truth.
But okay,
I know what you're probably thinking
right now.
I mean,
so what?
What was the problem with China trying
to increase their military after all,
it's just another country.
Everyone has an army and wants to be
safe rice.
I mean,
why should we care about China having
military basis?
Do they really want to surpass the
United States?
Can they even?
Well,
today we're going to answer all of those
questions,
but before we do,
as we always do,
let's take a look back at the history
lessons from the pain.
We said America is almost impossible to
invade.
Whilst there was an exception,
and that was in the year 1941,
when Japan bombed Pearl Harbor in
Hawaii,
a year later,
the Japanese invaded the Aleutian
islands in Alaska.
That was the moment when America learned
an important lesson.
Nobody is 100 percent safe.
It was also the time that they figured
they should probably care about
protecting the oceans.
In fact,
during World War Two,
the US had to fight among lots of small
islands in the Pacific.
This was the case during the battle of
midway after the attack on Pearl Harbor,
the Japanese trying to eliminate the US
as a strategic power in the Pacific and
they hope to succeed by demoralizing the
American forces with another surprise
attack,
American cryptographers.
They managed to decipher the date and
the location of Japan's attack and
prepared a surprise counterattack.
Needless to say,
the US inflicted irreparable damage to
the Japanese fleet.
World War Two ended.
The Americans won and they remembered
that lesson.
We can't let this happen again.
Sorry.
Well,
what did they do?
they covered the Pacific Ocean with
military basis.
Basically they kept soldiers on those
small islands where they had fought and
how you might be wondering,
well,
why is it so important to have soldiers
on a small island?
No one really cares about.
I mean,
is it really that bad if someone wants
to invade an asshole,
like midway,
I mean really and also moving soldiers
to the other side of the planet and
keeping them that it's not exactly
cheap.
Worship is basically a floating city
with big guns on it.
It's a city that can move travel 500 to
a thousand kilometers in one day,
so moving one of those from Los Angeles
to Shanghai will take more than 10 days,
but if
you already have ships in soldiers in
Guam,
you can be to Shanghai in almost three
days.
This is designed to deter potential
conflicts.
In fact,
most of those ships would never have to
fire a single weapon.
Being so powerful.
Bonnets name,
no one would probably dare to attack
them,
but not only that,
many of these ships are not meant to
combat other armies,
but rather than into combat pirates,
for example,
the USS Independence is a warship
created for the main purpose of
combating piracy,
and this is just one of many ships,
in fact to the U.
S naval forces getting bigger and bigger
all the time,
and this means that so far no one has
been able to match it.
Maybe to add 46 ships in five years,
but 355 ships won't come for a long
time.
Of course,
this gives America a huge amount of
power and this can be worrying to some
people,
but so far it's created a safe
environment where everybody can trade on
troubles whenever it some country or
some pirates,
once a block of trade routes,
they have to face all those American
ships.
This is one reason why Southeast Asian
nations have become exporting
powerhouses,
and of course it's benefited China.
Yeah.
The truth is that there are many
countries that would happily block
China's trade routes,
but it's China.
Comfortable in this position,
does it like depending so much on
America's army?
Well,
let's have a look.
New Hedge Lamont,
so what defines a territory or a
territory is an area of land onto the
jurisdiction of a ruler or a states.
Not all territories are born equal.
Some have abundant natural resources
like Jen's gas and oil,
while others basically having no
resources,
the availability of some resources gives
the country they belong to.
Some pretty big advantages in trade.
Most obvious example of this is oil and
how much she's trade as defined.
Saudi Arabia,
it's a common.
What about the others?
Those who have lists a few resources,
they need to import everything for their
industries.
They must compete with international
bitters to secure stable suppliers of
resources,
which basically means their industrial
cost of production is also going to be
higher and this,
this steer view is essentially China's
situation.
Yes,
China's got a lot of industry but almost
no resources,
oil,
steel,
uranium,
most of the things that needs to make
those mobile phones,
cars or tvs.
It's got to come from other parts of the
weld and this appetite for raw materials
is increasing every single day,
but this still isn't the end of our
story.
Once those resources are required,
China needs to transport them to its
territory safely and for as little money
as possible.
The South China Sea is the busiest
collection of shipping lanes in the
world.
It's the lifeblood of East Asia carrying
most of it straight in oil.
It's obvious then that China would very
much like to keep these lines of trade
open and preferably to control them.
It also doesn't have a big consumer
market like the U,
s.so
at wants to export a lot of what it
makes in order to make money and these
routes can be blocked at anytime by one
of their neighboring countries,
which would stop all of that from
happening.
The Communist Party,
the governing force in China also has a
lot of mouths to feed,
so control over this region is essential
if the party wants to stay in power.
All right,
so I can probably guess what you're
thinking right now.
You're probably thinking,
well,
shiner isn't the only one.
Many of the countries have no natural
resources either and they don't complain
of course,
but there is a big problem here being so
dependent on imports and exports.
China only needs one country to block
its roots,
to collapse it in a matter of months,
and as we mentioned before,
there are many countries who would very
happily do that,
especially one in particular,
and that's India.
You see the string of islands on the
Indian Ocean.
Well,
these belong to India and the Indian
army could block Chinese boats.
This would mean that China couldn't buy
most of the oil that they currently
consume.
Most of the oil tankers that go from the
Middle East to China pass through the
Strait of Malacca right where Singapore
is.
We're talking about almost 20 million
barrels of oil a day and many other
goods in addition,
but if India blocks the roots among
those small islands,
good luck trying to get that oil.
In fact,
there is such an existential threat to
China that their former president,
Hu Jintao,
used to call this the Malacca dilemma,
and we're not just talking about India.
In fact,
America isn't getting through their best
time when it comes to loving the Chinese
either and again,
the American navy,
it has the capabilities you block the
oil supply to China by sea.
This would be far more devastating than
any trade war so well.
What's the solution?
Belt and road initiative and its
maritime counterpart,
the string of pearls.
The belt and road initiative was
initiated by President Xi Jinping in
2013 with the aim of rebuilding
infrastructure and accelerating Chinese
economic growth.
Essentially,
this is a brand new silk road and the
string of pearls,
well,
that's its maritime brother.
In 2017 Mr.
she pledged an additional $124 billion
dollars towards says $900,000,000,000
belt and road initiative.
China is promoting this global trade
infrastructure as a longterm wind wind
campaign for the 65 nations that have
signed up it.
Most Western leaders,
however they stayed away from the
Chinese.
Some is announcing the ambitious
projects about so the 28 heads of state
presence at what Mr she called a
gathering of great minds included
President Putin of Russia and President
I get on of target.
This is indeed a gathering of great
minds in the coming two days.
I hope that by engaging in a full
exchange of views,
we will contribute to pursuing the belt
and road initiative,
a project of the century so that it will
benefit people across the world.
See jumping
with China,
consolidating its power in relationships
with countries all over the south China
Sea region.
It might become really difficult for the
United States to keep being the big boss
in charge of the region.
If China was to support the US,
the United States would lose all of its
deterrents power in this key region of
the globe and this would completely
change the rules of international trade.
Americans were pretty worried about this
now the other car,
the CIA went so far as to state that the
US has two major problems right now,
Russia and China and their efforts to
undermine the u.
s is influencing key regions like Africa
and the South China Sea,
not naive and we are taking significant
steps on the counter intelligence side
so that we have all the defenses that we
need us.
Africa commands,
General Thomas Wallet Houser.
Alright,
so I know you're thinking you're
probably thinking America.
It's an empire all over the world and
we're just talking about one small
region,
the south China Sea and yeah,
that's absolutely right.
In fact,
China is only threatening us dominance
in the south China Sea,
not the whole world,
but this region.
It really is the most important when it
comes to international trade.
And this is why the struggle is quite so
intense that the show,
it still goes on.
In fact,
China knows that if it goes too far with
building military basis,
the u s will call on its allies in the
region to do the same.
This would mean scaling up military
spending and look,
China and the US,
they might not be the best couple on the
planet,
but they kind of tolerate each other.
And also the US,
his allies in the region,
well,
they really do have a problem with
China.
We've got India,
which we mentioned previously.
There's also Japan among others,
and China does not want those guys to
increase their military presence.
This is why so far,
China is playing a very patient game.
It's a very longterm challenge and
longterm in Chinese,
that means really longterm.
We might be talking about decades out,
but despite the slow path,
you'd better remember the term string of
pearls because it's going to appear a
lot more in the newspapers.
This is going to be so important that at
the beginning of next year on visual
politic,
we're going to continue telling you more
about this in another series of videos
that we've got coming up,
so you don't want to miss those.
Please do not forget to subscribe to
this channel and hit that bell button so
you won't miss any posts.
But now the question is,
do you think that the string of pedals
is really such a threat to international
stability?
Where does the US go from here?
This is the beginning of the end for the
American empire.
Well,
please me if your answer in the comment
section below,
and of course don't forget to visit our
friends from reconsider media.com.
They're the podcast that provided the
vocals in this episode,
but we're not mind.
Also,
if you liked this video,
give it a like and as always,
I'll see you next time and if you want
to learn more about politics and hear
even more of my lovely voice,
you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsideredmedia.com
slash podcast.
See you there.